kontrollen aber wie die
gesundheitsminister wollen den
abrechnungsbetrug mit corona tests
erschweren
unklar bleibt wer dafür zuständig sein
soll wie viel steuern darf der staat von
der rente kassieren das bisherige system
könne künftige rentner benachteiligen
sagt der bundesfinanzhof und allen
warnungen zum trotz 16 millionen
deutsche rauchen aber es gibt
erfolgversprechende wege zum ausstieg
aus der sucht
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers kommen in einer neuen
woche und in allen guten abend um den
sportlichen teil dieses nachrichten
montags kümmert sich kristin otto
naja ich habe alles okay in fußball
guten abend wegen des verdachts auf
betrug bei corona tests wollen bund und
länder jetzt schärfere kontrollen nur
ist noch weitgehend ungeklärt wer die
machen soll
es geht darum dass manche anbieter
vielmehr tests abgerechnet haben sollen
als die tat tatsächlich gemacht haben
bekannt wurden bisher verdachtsfälle in
bayern und nordrhein westfalen
es gibt erste ermittlungen der
staatsanwaltschaft in deutschland gibt
es mittlerweile mehr als 20.000 test
stellen von verschiedenen anbietern
schauen wir mal im detail ins
bevölkerungsreichste bundesland
nordrhein-westfalen dort ist die anzahl
der test stellen geradezu explodiert
mitte märz waren das 1862 mit der april
5776 und mitte mai schon 8735 das
geschäft ist lukrativ der staat zahlt
für jeden test bis zu 18 euro
dabei müssen die tests zentren ihre
abrechnungen kaum belegen bisher aus
berlin heike slansky kostenlose corona
schnelltests für jedermann finanziert
mit steuergeldern offensichtlich ohne
ausreichende kontrollen wegen
betrugsverdachts in millionenhöhe
schiebt bundesgesundheitsminister sparen
beim bund länder treffen heute morgen
den schwarzen peter den ländern zu doch
die wehren sich seit die gar nichts
davon mit einem finger auf den anderen
zu zeigen da ist ein problem das muss
gelöst werden jeder hat die
verantwortung der bund hat sie sich für
das thema der abrechnungen die kann
nicht bei den ländern liegen spahns test
verordnung soll nun verschärft werden
ziel mehr kontrollen eine arbeitsgruppe
berät noch über das wie auch wenn es
schwarze schafe gegeben haben soll
insgesamt seien die tests zentren ein
erfolg so die bundesregierung
das ist ja hervorzuheben dass es
innerhalb sehr kurzer zeit gelungen ist
ein so dichtes netz von
testmöglichkeiten aufzubauen testungen
können lockerungen absichern und können
damit verhindern dass infektionszahlen
wieder steigen
betrug ist betrug die opposition will
das nicht gelten lassen erst in der
dritten welle wurde flächendeckend
getestet viel zu spät und überteuert die
schnitte zentren für die korona tests
wurden hastig und von den
regierungsvorhaben herr schlampig
eingeführt und darin sehe ich den
ursprung des problems für die
qualitätssicherung sind formal die
gesundheitsämter zuständig doch auch die
sehen nur begrenzte möglichkeiten die
gesundheitsämter prüfen die hygiene
standards in den tests zentren sind die
wege richtig sind die abstände richtig
diese kontrollen finden stichprobenweise
statt
wie gut sind die tests zentren wie
aussagekräftig die tests die politik im
zugzwang
dann schauen wir uns jetzt die aktuelle
infektions lage in deutschland ran da
setzt sich der positive trend fort das
robert koch institut meldet 1978 neue
corona fälle das sind 700 4 weniger als
vergangenen montag 36 todesfälle kamen
dazu die bundesweite sieben tage
incidents sinkt auf 35,1 ab einer
inzidenz unter 50 heißt das ja ein
lichtblick für die gebeutelte
tourismusbranche
ab heute dürfen etwa im saarland hotels
wieder öffnen und restaurants und cafés
auch innen wieder gäste begrüßen
doch uneingeschränkte jubelstimmung löst
das nicht aus wie verena garrett
berichtet
die gäste können kommen letzte
vorbereitungen in der siegzeit lodge in
lohfelden eine stunde von saarbrücken
entfernt
sieben monate ist es her dass hier in
der hotelküche für viele gekocht wurde
jetzt bereitet sich das küchenteam
wieder auf lange tage vor die
herausforderung diesmal besteht auch
darin dass halt auch die lieferanten
halt noch hinter hecken mit der ware
das heißt da habe ich alle produkte
bekommen die wir eigentlich gewollt
hätten und von daher ein bisschen
umswitchen viele mitarbeiter waren
monatelang in kurzarbeit manche sind
ganz abgesprungen es war ein hartes jahr
neben den hotels dürfen die
gastronomiebetreiber im saarland auch
die innenbereiche wieder öffnen um
überbrückungshilfen wäre es für die
meisten in der branche nicht gegangen
damit konnten sie immerhin die fixkosten
decken vor der finanziellen situation
her müssen wir sagen ist die lage sehr
angespannt
wir stellen fest dass das eigenkapital
in weiten teilen bereits aufgebraucht
wurde rücklagen sind durch die bank
eigentlich kaum noch vorhanden doch auch
mit dem neubeginn ist bei weitem nicht
alles wieder gut
nicht gegessen das schnitzel wird nicht
doppelt gegessen
ein nicht getrunken es bier wirklich
doppelt getrunken
das kriegen sie nie wieder rein und im
moment sind ja auch noch auflagen da wir
haben die abstandsregeln das heißt sie
können ihre betriebe auch nicht auf
volllast fahren auf volllast fahren das
können sie auch in der siegzeit lötzsch
nicht 70 prozent der zimmer dürfen in
hotels vorerst belegt werden
immerhin die nachfrage sei groß und
jetzt ein weiteres sehr wichtiges thema
heute die bundesregierung plant die
beiträge zur altersvorsorge schneller
steuerfrei zu stellen als geplant sie
würde damit die konsequenzen ziehen aus
einem urteil des obersten deutschen
finanzgerichts die richter dort haben
heute zwar zwei aktuelle fälle
abgewiesen aber mit blick auf künftige
rentner jahrgänge klargemacht der
gesetzgeber müsse viel besser darauf
achten dass es keine verbotene doppelte
besteuerung von beiträgen und von renten
gibt das urteil hat es in sich für die
einzelnen rentner und für den staat
details von christoph schneider
sein stuhl im sitzungssaal des
bundesfinanzhofs blieb heute leer kläger
horst bangert stattdessen verfolgte er
bei sich zu hause die für ihn negative
entscheidung der bundesfinanzhof weist
seine klage ab weil seine ehefrau und
ihm liege keine verbotene
doppelbesteuerung vor
nach dem urteil des gerichts wurden die
renten des klägers zu treffen besteuert
allerdings werden künftige rentner in
sehr vielen fällen von der
verfassungswidrigen doppelbesteuerung
betroffen sein
das umstrittene prinzip ein teil der
beiträge zur gesetzlichen
rentenversicherung wird bis 2024
steuerlich belastet wenn auch zu einem
immer geringeren ausmaß erst ab 2025
sind sie wirklich steuerfrei
gleichzeitig wird ein teil der
gesetzlichen rente zum zu versteuernden
einkommen gezählt für jeden neuen
rentnerjahrgang wächst dieser teil der
2040 in rente geht muss seine gesamte
rente versteuern
zahlreiche künftige rentner wären also
von einer doppelbesteuerung betroffen
viele steuerzahler für viele rentner die
zukünftige rente gehen werden ist das
urteil durchaus positiv war das gericht
eben festgestellt hat dass die
berechnungsmethode so wie es die
finanzverwaltung bisher angewendet hat
unter einbeziehung des grundfreibetrags
unter einbeziehung von steuerfreien
abzügen für pflege und
krankenversicherung nicht korrekt ist
der finanzminister will zügig reagieren
ich bin dafür dass wir schnell handeln
und werde mich dafür einsetzen dass es
auch dazu kommt horst bangert hat seine
klage zwar verloren aber die zukünftigen
rentnerinnen und rentner können jetzt
auf günstigere regelungen hoffen
gut also wir haben gelernt viele können
jetzt hoffen müssen trotzdem noch mal
drüber reden christian decker aus
unserer rechts redaktion wen betrifft
das denn jetzt ganz konkret in zukunft
ja besonders betroffen sind alle
zukünftigen rentnerinnen und rentnern
anders formuliert alle die jetzt mitten
im berufsleben stehen ganz besonders die
die sie jetzt ungefähr mitte ende
vierzig sind
das gericht hat darüber hinaus auch noch
drei gruppen ausgemacht die zusätzlich
betroffen sind
das sind zum einen selbstständige diesen
mehr betroffen als angestellte männer
sind mehr betroffen als frauen
und unverheiratete sind mehr betroffen
als verheiratete
wichtig dabei ist aber diese aussagen
gelten nur wenn die regeln für die
rentenbesteuerung genau so bleiben wie
sie jetzt im moment sind dann machen wir
nochmal inhaltlich das ist ja sehr
kompliziertes die ganze materie mal so
einen strich drunter wenn man so will
die es geht darum eine doppelte
besteuerung zu vermeiden das haben wir
verstanden die richter stellen da jetzt
heute so eine gesamtrechnung an
was kann man denn generell aus diesem
urteil heute mitnehmen die richterinnen
und richter haben denn jetzt ein
bisschen salopp formulieren will dem
gesetzgeber in der hausaufgabe gegeben
die haben eine konkrete regelung
aufgestellt wie diese doppelbesteuerung
konkret berechnet wird
der gesetzgeber kann nun seine gesetze
so anpassen dass es den regeln des
bundesfinanzhofs entspricht und
bundesfinanzminister scholz hat ja heute
genau das angekündigt die beiträge zur
rente sollen weniger besteuert werden in
zukunft allerdings will er das erst nach
der bundestagswahl durchführen also erst
in der neuen legislaturperiode
wenn also an dem thema dranbleiben
müssen christian vielen dank und viel
mehr dazu auch gleich nach und bei wieso
hier im zdf ausspähen unter freunden das
geht gar nicht hatte die bundeskanzlerin
2013 gesagt nachdem die usa auch ihr
handy angezapft hatten
jetzt bekommt dieser satz möglicherweise
eine neue bedeutung das eu land dänemark
soll laut medienberichten den
amerikanern beim ausspionieren geholfen
haben
mit einer geheimen ab hörstation
reaktionen auf die affäre heute auch bei
den deutsch-französischen
regierungsgesprächen inakzeptabel sei
eine solche aktion unter bündnispartnern
sagt frankreichs präsident manual makro
er und die bundeskanzlerin forderte
absolute transparenz von der dänischen
regierung und von den usa
es sieht so aus als ginge in israel
jetzt eine politische ära zu ende die
von ministerpräsident benjamin netanjahu
insgesamt 15 jahre war er mahnt die
letzten zwölf hintereinander weg
zerbrochene regierungskoalitionen
neuwahlen und auch ein
korruptionsverfahren konnten ihm nichts
anhaben doch jetzt verbünden sich seine
gegner und zwar quer durch alle lager
von links liberal bis rechts national
aus tel aviv berichtet michael waginger
lange waren die mehrheiten in der
knesset unklar nach der wahl im märz
dann kam noch ein krieg dazu der das
land und die region zerriss und doch
scheint jetzt das unmögliche möglich
durch ihn oppositionsführer ja ihr la
pete von der liberalen zukunftspartei er
brachte die denkt bei
unterschiedlichsten lager zusammen
gesetzt wenn die zukunftspartei 40 sitze
hätte würde ich diese regierung bilden
rechts links mitte eine regierung der
einheit eine regierung die sich um alle
bürger kümmert auch wenn sie uns nicht
gewählt haben
wie ernst der liberale lappi das meint
zeigt sich darin dass er dem
rechtsnationalen nach der die band den
vortritt als ministerpräsident lässt
obwohl der nicht mal die hälfte der
mandate von der pis partei hat eine
moderne ich erkläre hier und heute dass
ich alles tun werde um eine nationale
einheitsregierung mit meinem freund ja
ihr lappi zu bilden und mit gottes hilfe
werden wir zusammen das land aus der
krise herausführen
er ist der große verlierer
benjamin netanjahu seit zwölf jahren
dauer premierminister
er hat seine verdienste für das land
aber auch seine skandale
aktuell steht der wegen
korruptionsverdacht vor gericht der
premier posten schützt die in lange
davor
am ende wollten selbst die
rechtskonservativen nicht mehr mit dem
mann zusammen gehen den sie als großen
spalter sehen eine kurve ich rufe alle
aus dem rechten lager dazu auf bildet
nicht diese linke regierung diese
regierung ist eine gefahr für die
sicherheit israels und friede zukunft
des landes
doch noch steht die neue
minderheitsregierung nicht und israel
ist ein gespaltenes land dann die
gretchenfrage jetzt nach jerusalem
michael namen wie viel zukunft kann denn
so eine schillernde neue mammut
konstellation in israels politik haben
naja diese mammut koalition wäre vor
allem erst mal eine minderheitsregierung
und zwar eine des kleinsten gemeinsamen
nenners und der heißt alles außer
netanjahu eine gemeinsame politische
agenda ist bisher nicht zu erkennen und
man kann sich kaum vorstellen wie ein
zum teil rechtsnationalistische dann
ministerpräsident nach der liebert der
bisher vor allem siedler interessen
vertreten hat mit koalitionsmitgliedern
von der arbeiterpartei die sich als
einer der wenigen noch ganz offen für
eine zwei staaten lösung mit den
palästinensern aussprechen wie die
zusammenarbeiten sollen
im moment gibt es gerade hauen und
stechen um posten und pöstchen es wird
mit rückzug und rücktritt gedroht
eigentlich hätte man sich geeinigt die
streitthemen erst einmal auszuklammern
die frage ist nur was dann noch übrig
bleibt viele fragen weiterhelfen in
israel michael herzlichen dank nach
jerusalem
berlin gilt als drehkreuz für den
menschenverachtenden handel mit
vietnamesinnen und vietnamesen ein
illegales europa weiteres geschäft bei
einer razzia wurden jetzt zwei
mutmaßliche drahtzieher rinnen
festgenommen 700 polizisten waren in
mehreren bundesländern im einsatz
schleuser sollen pro person bis zu
21.000 euro verlangt haben
wer das geld nicht aufbringen konnte
musste es abarbeiten in massagestudios
etwa oder durch prostitution ganz
anderes thema jetzt in der sendung heute
ist weltnichtrauchertag anlass auf ein
problem zu schauen denn für sehr viele
menschen in deutschland ist tag für tag
raucher tag regelmäßig zur zigarette
greifen gut 16 millionen deutsche eine
gefährliche sucht an den folgen sterben
bei uns jedes jahr mehr als 127.000
menschen gesundheits organisationen
fordern von der politik jetzt mehr
bemühungen gegen das rauchen einer werk
zehn zigaretten am tag für petra war das
jahrelang normal jetzt hat er aufgehört
akupunktur hilft ihm gegen die
entzugserscheinungen in den situationen
[Musik]
gewöhnt habe war ich super eigentlich
wenden kann wenn ich mich geraucht haben
im gefühl da wo sie tätig beispielsweise
auch weil der 33 jährige vater wurde hat
er sich beim entwicklungsprogramm hier
am klinikum stuttgart angemeldet
in deutschland raucht mehr als jeder
vierte mann und fast jede fünfte frau
obwohl die meisten wissen wie schädlich
es ist das kann es schwere
abhängigkeitserkrankungen sein und dann
geht es mit vielen symptomen hier diese
schwierig machen mit dem rauchen direkt
aufzuhören
ein fast tabakfreie ist deutschland 2040
fordert jetzt das deutsche
krebsforschungszentrum zusammen mit rund
50 gesundheitsorganisationen raucher zum
rauchstopp zu motivieren und
gleichzeitig jugendliche vom einstieg
ins rauchen abzuhalten sind deutliche
tabaksteuererhöhungen die regelmäßig
stattfinden und die auch den preis dann
wirklich erhöhen mindestens 10%
tabaksteuererhöhung jährlich sei
notwendig bei der umsetzung von
maßnahmen zur senkung des tabakkonsums
ist deutschland bisher schlusslicht in
europa die tabaklobby tritt in
deutschland sehr stark auf sie geht
politikern um politiker ein sie umgarnt
sie es fließen sehr viele gelder an die
parteien während andere gruppen die eher
gesundheitliche interessen im blick
haben nicht mit derselben stärke
auftreten tabakfreie 2040 tempeh tram
ist sondern auf einem guten weg dahin
wie schnell sich der körper durchaus vom
langjährigen rauchen erholen kann was
also nach dem aufhören alles in uns drin
passiert mehr dazu online bei zdf heute
oder in unserer app nach der erzwungenen
landung einer ryanair maschine in
belarus hat man genauer hin wenn wieder
einer maschine außerplanmäßig landen
muss passiert ist das gestern abend in
berlin
bange stunden für 165 ryanair passagiere
ursache war eine bombendrohung das
flugzeug wurde evakuiert und von der
polizei durchsucht verdächtiges wurde
nicht gefunden
die maschine war auf dem weg von dublin
nach krakau um gegen 4 uhr morgens
durften die gestrandeten dann ihre reise
fortsetzen
in einem ersatzflugzeug und damit sind
wir heute abend bei kristin otto und wir
müssen auch mal aufs eis trotz
sommergefühle so langsam wird es eng für
die deutschen eishockey spieler bei der
weltmeisterschaft im lettischen riga
verheißungsvollen turnier einstieg mit
drei siegen gab es vorhin die dritte
niederlage nacheinander 0 2 gegen die
usa keine tore im ersten drittel aber
dafür setzte es treffer der anderen art
eine hart umkämpfte partie früh zeigt
sich dass die deutschen im vorletzten
gruppenspiel gegen das favorisierte us
team nicht klein beigeben werden im
zweiten drittel drängt deutschland auf
die führung doch sie will trotz
zweimaliger über teilen nicht gelingen
als dann holzer auf die strafbank muss
schlagen die amerikaner eiskalt zu
gallens schuss abgefälscht und dann
tunnelt robertson deutschland starken
torwart rückmann 10 usa
im schlussdrittel alles oder nichts 30
zu elf torschüsse doch wieder knapp
vorbei es ist wie verhext kurz vor
schluss trifft blackwell dann auch noch
zum 2 0 endstand für die usa
deutschland muss morgen gegen gastgeber
lettland gewinnen um ins viertelfinale
einzuziehen
zurück zur rieger mentalität so das
motto im trainingslager der
fußball-nationalmannschaft in seefeld
mittwochabend das erste von zwei
testspielen gegen dänemark bei dem
allerdings noch sieben der 26 em spieler
fehlen werden auch am vierten tag in
tirol muss der bundestrainer auf toni
kroos verzichten nach überstandener
krone infektion und zwei wochen in
quarantäne absolvierte er am frühen
abend eine individuelle einheit
steigt aber erst ins team training ein
wenn alle medizinischen untersuchungen
unauffällig sind bereits seit freitag
ist rückkehrer mats hummels aktiv
topmotiviert und angetan vom
leistungsniveau in der dfb auswahl
jetzt habe ich hier das ist vier
einheiten seien miterlebt die waren
durchweg positiv wirklich mit hoher
qualität hohe leistungsbereitschaft und
das stimmt mich schon mal sehr
zuversichtlich dass wir eben auf das
gewünschte niveau kommen bis spätestens
zum 15 06
hummels klagen leichte knieprobleme sein
comeback beim test gegen dänemark soll
aber nicht gefährdet sein
das wird dann in innsbruck sein mit
vorabend eine schöne kompakte
sporteinheit vielen dank das sehen geht
nicht gibt's nicht gilt auch für 3d
drucker dieser hier in belgien ist
europas größter spezial printer und er
spuckt dann auch gleich ein ganzes haus
aus beton statt tinte 90 quadratmeter
statt dina4 alles fertig in nur drei
wochen zwei stöcke ich begehbar und
niemand musste wegen papierstau oder
lehrer patrone an die decke gehen
das gedruckte haus sieht ganz niedlich
aus morgen beginnt der meteorologische
sommer was der uns bringt erfahren wir
gleich von katja horneffer im heute
journal hat die kollegin marietta slomka
den blick auf diese welt um 21 uhr 45
wir hier danken für ihr interesse
gern bis morgen in einer angenehm haben
[Musik]
den abend meine damen und herren der
strahlend sonnige letzte meiler kann
nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen dass der
meteorologische frühling also die
kalender monate märz april und mai
deutlich zu kalt war nämlich 1,7 grad
kälter als im vieljährigen
klimatologischen mittel der jahre bei 3
91 bis 2020 zu erwarten gewesen wäre
der hochnebel hat sich schnell verzogen
und sonst gab es heute nachmittag nur so
ein paar kleine quellwolken und auch
heute nacht gibt es allenfalls im
nordosten ein paar wolkenfelder sonst
ist es klar und es wird zum teig kalt
die temperaturen sinken zum beispiel in
bayern und auch in sachsen auf 3 grad
morgen gibt es dagegen bis zu 26 grad
nämlich hier am niederrhein deutlich
kühler bleibt es morgen an der ostsee da
sind dass höchstens 17 grad und das
liegt an dichteren wolken die da herr
einziehen
da sind sie am nachmittag durchaus vor
einigen gewittern oder kurzen schauern
zwischen der oder mündung und der
lausitz nicht ganz sicher anders sieht
es aus südlich von erzgebirge thüringer
wald rhön westerwald und eifel
da scheint die sonne zum teil strahlen
bei ostwind aber auch in süddeutschland
gibt es ein west-ost-gefälle am
alpenrand sind oft nur 20 grad im westen
bis zu 26 grad sommerlich geht es auch
weiter
allerdings steigt die gewittergefahr
deutlich an schönen abend noch